Prof: So in 1832,
as we saw at the end last time,
Wöhler went to work for
most of a month with Liebig,
and together they worked on the
oil of bitter almonds,
which is making its way around
-- it's benzaldehyde --
here.
So there's the bottle that's
coming around.
What did you notice about it?
Where is it?
What do you notice about it
Devin?
Student:
>
Prof: Yeah.
Student:  About the
smell?
Prof: What does it smell
like?
Is it almonds?
Turn it around,
look at the -- turn it upside
down.
What do you notice?
Student:  There's a
little bit of solid in the
bottom.
Prof: Yeah,
it's half solid.
Benzaldehyde is the oil
of bitter almonds;
not the solid of bitter almonds.
What does it say on the label,
written by hand?
Somebody's initials, J.W.
Student: J.W., 11/29/95.
Prof: So it was opened
in 1995, thirteen years ago.
When it was opened it was a
liquid.
Now it's half solid.
How do you figure that?
Well something must've happened.
So what did it react with,
in the bottle?
Yoonjoo?
Student:  Oxygen.
Prof: Oxygen.
Okay?
So oil of bitter almonds;
they analyzed,
C_7H_6O, and they found that it
reacted with oxygen to get
C_7H_6O_2.
Right?
They also reacted it with
bromine.
The halogens were common,
as we'll see,
for reagents in those days.
Got C_7H_5OBr.
They reacted it with chlorine,
and also that product with
potassium iodide,
or ammonia, or lead sulfide.
And they got all these
compounds.
And what did they do with them
when they got them?
They smelled them. Right?
What was the main thing they
did?
Student:  Tasted it.
Prof: No that's not the
--
it's true that they probably
tasted,
that they tasted them,
but that's not the main thing
they did that gave them unique
information.
Student:  Weight.
Prof: What about the
weight?
What was the main technique
that we've been talking about
all the time?
Dana?
Student:  The analysis
of combustion.
Prof: They did an
elemental analysis;
ultimate analysis of what the
ratio of the elements.
So that's what they had. Right?
So big deal.
What do you get from the
analysis?
What can you infer?
Here were these guys;
you could now compete with
them, right?
This is what they found out
during that month of
experimentation,
and they came up with a theory
that revolutionized organic
chemistry,
as of that time and for the
next twenty years.
So what did they notice?
Claire?
Student: They noticed
the carbon chains.
Prof: Pardon me?
Student: The carbon
chains.
Prof: Well how would you
know it's a chain?
The numbers don't tell you it's
a chain.
What?
Student: The presence of
the hydrocarbons.
Prof: Well it's,
it's got hydrogen and carbon in
it.
That's true.
But they also have oxygen and
nitrogen, chlorine and other
things.
What could you make out of this?
Brian?
Student: C_7H_5.
Prof: Yeah.
All of them have at least
C_7H_5.
Some of them have more hydrogen
than that, but nothing has less
than C_7 or less than H_5.
Can anybody carry that any
further?
Student: C_7H_5 is
non-reactive.
Prof: Pardon me?
Student: It's non -- the
C_7H_5 is the unreactive part.
Prof: Yeah.
What would they have called it;
the thing that you have it
there and then it reacts and
gives this, that,
or the other thing?
What did Lavoisier call it?
Student:  The radical.
Prof: The base,
or the radical.
But actually the radical is
more than C_7H_5,
the thing that persists.
What else?
Prof: O.
So C_7H_5O persists through all
these transformations.
So it looks like that's some
sort of a core that gets
modified.
Okay?
But it's there all the time.
It's like a radical. Right?
So it was called the benzoyl
radical.
They thought up that name at
that time, and the idea of using
the suffix -yl,
to denote a radical.
So if you denote the benzoyl
radical by Bz --
you see that you started,
the oil of bitter almonds is
BzH,
and then the acid is BzOH,
and the acid chloride is BzCl
and Br and I and NH_2 and two
Bz's,
together with S, at the end.
Okay?
So a radical can be the base of
more than just an acid.
Right?
Lavoisier had the idea that you
react it with oxygen and you get
an acid.
But here you can react it with
all sorts of different things
and get different compounds.
But the base is still there,
the benzoyl radical.
So this gave rise to the idea
of organic dualism.
Remember, we had this dualism
last time.
There were positive things and
negative things and they could
associate and trade partners.
But maybe the difference in
organic chemistry is that you
have radicals,
things that are plus or minus,
but they're more complicated
than just single atoms.
There are combinations of
elements that function in
organic chemistry;
and that's what makes it
different from inorganic,
according to this theory.
So then the idea is to find all
these organic radicals,
that make organic chemistry
special.
So during the 1830s these
compound radicals were
discovered everywhere.
For example,
in Germany, Liebig found
acetyl.
And Bunsen, in Heidelberg,
found cacodyl;
which is named because it
smells so awful.
Right?
Or Berzelius in Sweden found
ethyl.
Or Piria in Italy got salicyl.
And Dumas got a whole bunch of
them, in Paris:
methyl, cinnamyl,
cetyl, ethylene.
All these radicals were
discovered.
So the thought was this is the
way to organize organic
chemistry.
And that theory,
the dualism applied to organic
theory, the radical theory,
survives today in our
nomenclature.
Right?
So, for example,
we talk about ethyl chloride.
That's not one word,
it's two words,
with a space.
Right?
And the reason is it's
dualistic.
It's a positive ethyl and a
minus chlorine.
Right?
So it's two things that have
come together.
Okay, now the -yl part,
that Wöhler and Liebig
thought up,
comes from a Greek word,
üleh,
which means wood or matter.
So it's the substance of stuff.
Okay, so now ether was
something that had been known
for a long time,
and it came from a Greek root
which means to shine.
So in the 1700s it was -- so it
had been applied to the sky.
It was transferred from the
idea of shining,
to the idea of the clear sky,
and from that to a colorless
liquid.
So when they distilled
something out of alcohol that
had been treated with acid,
and they got this clear stuff
that was clear as the sky,
they called it ether. Right?
Which we call diethyl ether
nowadays.
So that's where
"ether"
came from.
So hence eth-yl was the
matter that appears in ether.
So it was like two benzoyl
radicals with sulfur.
Right?
You can have two ethyl radicals
with oxygen.
Right?
And that was then eth-yl
-- right?
-- the material of ether.
Okay?
How about methyl?
Well meth comes from the
Greek word meaning wine or
spirit.
Right?
And the -yl,
that same root,
but a different meaning this
time.
Remember, it can mean matter --
that was the one before -- or it
can mean wood,
and in this case it means wood.
So what does it mean,
meth-yl,
if the -yl means not the
substance of but means wood?
Student: From wood.
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  From wood.
Prof: From wood.
What from wood?
Student:  Wine.
Prof: The spirits,
from wood.
So you've heard methanol called
wood alcohol -- right?
-- because you get it from
distilling it.
But the first word was
methylene, and ene is the
Greek feminine patronymic;
it means "the daughter
of."
And ene,
ine, one,
all of those are like that;
like Persephone,
or Antigone means the "one
who goes against her
parents,"
and so on.
So ene was the Greek --
so what did meth-yl-ene mean?
It meant the daughter of wood
spirits.
So the theory was that wood
spirits, that is,
wood alcohol,
was a combination of methylene
plus water.
So methylene thus,
if wood alcohol is CH_3OH,
then methylene was
CH_2_; which then you
add water and you get wood
alcohol.
So that's where the name
methylene came from.
Right?
So then in 1840 -- that was
1835, so five years later --
they decided that they needed
the radical CH_3.
So they named it methyl,
from methylene.
Right?
And then ethylene came;
that name came in 1852,
because it was related to
ethyl, which had already been
named, the same way that
methylene was related to methyl.
Okay?
So that's where these names
came from.
They all have their root in the
radical theory.
Now, that's C_1 and C_2,
methyl and ethyl.
How about C_3 and C_4,
do you know what they're named?
Roots?
How about C_3,
do you know what C _3 alcohol
is?
Students:  Propyl.
Prof: Propyl.
And C_4?
Students:  Butyl.
Prof: Butyl.
So where do those names come
from?
Okay, C_3H_7_ is
propyl, and by the same
reasoning as before,
C_3H_6 is propylene;
or propene, sometimes it
shortened.
Okay?
And butyl and butylene,
or butene.
Okay, now butylene comes -- the
C_4 acid is butyric acid,
which had already been named,
because it's the stuff that
makes rancid butter smell bad.
Okay?
So people worked it up and
found butyric acid;
so that's where butyl comes
from.
But how about propyl?
It has a very much more
interesting origin.
Okay, so protos means
first, and pion means
fat.
So propion was the first fat.
In what sense?
Well these carboxylic acids
came from fats,
right?
And they were called fatty
acids.
And they behaved like fats,
they dissolved in organic
solvents.
Right?
But the very -- the ones with
the fewest number of carbons,
with just one carbon -- that's
formic acid that you get by
destructive distillation of
ants,
or acetic acid,
from vinegar -- those are
miscible with water.
But the C_3 is the first one
that's not freely miscible with
water;
it behaves more like a fat.
Right?
So the first fatty acid is
propionic acid.
So propyl, propylene are the
C_3s.
Okay, after that you get into
numbers, the roots for numbers.
So Jean-Baptiste André
Dumas was the successor of
Gay-Lussac as the spokesman for
French chemistry.
You see, he was born on the
14th of July,
a reasonable date for somebody
to lead French chemistry,
in 1800.
So for eighty-four years --
well, for part of eighty-four
years, he was the leader of
French chemistry.
There he is with some
decoration on him.
I'm not sure what it is.
I'd like to find out.
So he was the Post-Napoleonic
guardian of the French tradition
of chemistry.
The French had what most people
regard as a terrible system,
which is they had chairs,
you know, for professors.
But you could have more than
one chair.
So a single individual could
tie up three different
appointments,
and you didn't have as many
people able to exercise their
ingenuity in developing
chemistry.
So he had the chair at the
Sorbonne;
also the École
Polytechnique and the
École de Médicine.
And he was a persistent
opponent of Liebig and
Berzelius.
But in 1837,
after this radical stuff got
going --
and he had discovered four
radicals himself,
of which he was quite pleased
-- he and Liebig happened to
meet during a speaking tour in
England,
and they got in conversation,
and Dumas decided,
on the basis of that meeting --
though not Liebig --
that they were now great
friends and could collaborate
from here on in.
So he wrote this long thing,
in flowery French,
in 1837, "A Note on the
Present State of Organic
Chemistry."
So this is five years after the
Radical Theory began.
He said: "Sixty years have
hardly passed since the ever
memorable time when this same
assembly"
--
he was speaking to the Paris
Academy --
"heard the first
discussions of the fertile
chemical doctrine which we owe
to the genius of Lavoisier.
This short span of time has
sufficed to examine fully the
most delicate questions of
inorganic chemistry,
and anyone can easily convince
himself that this branch of our
knowledge possesses almost
everything that it can with the
methods of observation
available."
So check off inorganic
chemistry, we've got that now.
Okay?
"There barely remain a few
cracks here and there to fill
in."
So this is the persistent
myopia of leaders of science.
As I mentioned before,
when we were speaking of
Lavoisier, this certainly
persists 'til today.
So Dumas goes on:
"In a word,
how with the help of the laws
of inorganic chemistry can"
--
incidentally,
this is all one sentence,
of course.
This is "in a word",
right?
So he really liked speaking,
right?;
flowery language.
"How with the help of the
laws of inorganic chemistry can
one explain and classify such
varied substances as one obtains
from organic bodies,
and which nearly always are
formed only of carbon,
hydrogen, and oxygen,
to which elements nitrogen is
sometimes joined?"
So if it's all in the analysis
of what atoms are there,
how can you have so many
different things?
Right?
"This was the great and
beautiful question of natural
philosophy,
a question well designed to
excite the highest degree of
competition among
chemists."
Name two, right?
"For once resolved the
most beautiful triumphs were
promised to science.
The mysteries of plants,
the mysteries of animal life
would be unveiled before our
eyes;
we would seize the key to all
the changes of matter,
so sudden, so swift,
so singular,
that occur in animals and
plants;
more importantly we would find
means of duplicating them in our
laboratories."
(This would make a good
research proposal,
right?)
"Well, we are not afraid
to say it,
and it is not an assertion
which we make lightly:
this great and beautiful
question is today answered;
it only remains to follow
through on all the consequences
which the solution entails.
In fact to produce with three
or four elements such varied
combinations,
more varied perhaps than those
which make up the whole
inorganic kingdom,
nature has chosen a path as
simple as it was unexpected;
for with elements she has made
compounds which behave in all
their properties like elements
themselves."
(That is, radicals -- right?
-- that persist through these
reactions.)
"And this,
we are convinced,
is the entire secret of organic
chemistry."
Great and beautiful questions
to answer.
It only remains to follow
through the consequences;
compounds which behave like
elements.
"Thus organic chemistry
possesses in its own elements,
which sometimes play the role
of chlorine or oxygen"
--
what does he mean,
play the role of chlorine and
oxygen?
How come radicals sometimes
play the role of chlorine and
oxygen?
What would that role be?
Student:
>
Prof: Pardon me?
Student: Oxidation.
Prof: No.
What roles do things play in
this theory that he's using?
Lucas?
Student:  Plus and minus.
Prof: Plus and minus.
So sometimes they're like
chlorine or oxygen.
What does that mean?
Students:  Negative.
Prof: Sometimes they're
negative, right?
"And sometimes,
on the contrary,
they play the role of
metals."
Sometimes they're positive.
"Cyanogen, amide, benzoyl,
the radicals of ammonia,
of aliphatics,
of alcohol, and analogous
substances,
these are the true elements
with which organic chemistry
operates.
To discover these radicals,
to study them,
to characterize them,
has been our daily study for
ten years."
(Okay?
So they're plus and they're
minus.)
"Sometimes, none the less,
our opinions have appeared to
differ,
and then, with each of us drawn
on by the heat of our battle
with nature,
there arose between us
discussions whose liveliness we
both regret.
Actually when we were able to
discuss questions which
separated us in several friendly
meetings,
we soon realized that we were
in agreement on the
principles….
We then understood that united
we could undertake a task before
which either of us in isolation
would have recoiled….
We will analyze every organic
substance...
to establish reliably what sort
of radical it refers
to…."
So that is what everybody
should do.
Then you'll know all about
organic chemistry.
"Each of us has,
in fact, opened his laboratory
to all young men who were
motivated by true love of
science;
they have seen all,
understood all.
We have worked under their
eyes, and have had them work
under ours,
in such a way that we are
surrounded by young rivals,
who are the hope of science,
and whose work will be added to
ours and mingle with ours,
for it will have been conceived
in the same spirit and carried
out by the same method."
Right?
So if everybody does what we
say they should do,
then we got it.
Okay?
"This is not an effort
conceived for personal gain or
in the interest of narrow
vanity."
Far be it from us.
"No, and in a
collaboration which is perhaps
unheard of in the history of
science,
this is an undertaking in which
we hope to interest every
chemist in Europe."
So everyone should work on this.
So we'll go to the funding
agencies and tell them this is
the only kind of research you
should fund;
forget these other guys out
there.
This is true love of
science, right?
And conceived in the same
spirit and carried out by the
same methods.
So this is megalomania,
and doesn't show much
imagination.
Now, but there was a problem
with dualism.
So, for example,
suppose you have benzoyl
chloride,
which remember was by reacting
benzaldehyde or benzoyl hydride
with chlorine,
and you get benzoyl chloride
and HCl as the other product.
Now HCl is quite clear,
it's H+ and Cl-.
What's benzoyl chloride?
It's obviously benzoyl+ and Cl-.
And what problem does that
create?
What, Russell?
Student: The benzoyl is
minus before,
but hydrogen --
Prof: Ah ha.
But how do you get benzoyl
hydride, plus,
plus?
Right?
So there's something weird
going on.
So this is a problem.
In the 1840s and 1850s,
the French discovered a
competing theory --
or invented,
I should say -- a competing
theory called the substitution
theory,
or the type theory,
or the unitary theory,
as opposed to the dualistic
theory,
the plus, minus idea.
So these began to compete with
one another.
And it started at a ball in the
Tuileries Palace in 1830.
This picture is from 40 years
later, or 37 years later.
But what happened is they got
the ball started,
all the people came dressed up
fancy,
and they began to cough and
choke because the room was
filled with some noxious gas.
And when they discovered it
came from the candles,
they asked Dumas to look into
it.
And he identified the culprit
as HCl, because it turned out
that the candles were very
white.
The wax had been bleached with
chlorine, and when they were
burned HCl was given off.
So the question is,
what is it that holds chlorine?
How did this fat,
in the candles,
fix chlorine gas?
Well you're in a position to
understand that now.
We can think about mechanisms;
in fact, two ways that the
hydrocarbon could fix chlorine.
Now, suppose we try -- there's
chlorine that is being used to
bleach the stuff.
Let's try for a HUMO/LUMO
approach.
What makes chlorine reactive?
High HOMO or low LUMO?
What's unusual about chlorine?
Student:  Low LUMO.
Prof: Pardon me?
Prof: Why do you say so
Claire?
What is the low LUMO?
Student:  It's the Cl-Cl
bond.
Prof: Right,
the Ïƒ* of Cl-Cl,
which is low because chlorine
has a high nuclear charge.
Okay, now we need a HOMO to
react with it.
Now, one of the more
interesting hydrocarbons,
in this regard,
is one that had been known
already, for fourty years,
to react with chlorine.
And it was because of that
reaction it was called the
"olefiant gas",
and was by this time known to
be C_2H_4.
Right?
So we would write it with a
double bond.
"Olefiant",
because ole,
oil, and fiant,
to make;
so it's the stuff that makes
oil.
Right?
And we'll see the reaction that
makes oil here,
its reaction with chlorine.
So what makes the olefiant gas
reactive?
Kevin?
Student:  Poor overlap.
Prof: Right,
so poor overlap makes a high
HOMO.
And remember the name of it?
Student:  Ï€.
Prof: Ï€.
So the Ï€ electrons
because of poor overlap are a
high HOMO.
So we can use those electrons
to mix with the low LUMO;
and again, one of these
make-and-break situations.
And chloride leaves and you get
this thing, which has a positive
charge.
Now that thing itself is
reactive.
What do you make -- where is a
low LUMO in this one?
Pardon me?
Student:  On the
positive charge.
Prof: Speak up please.
Student:  On the
positive charge.
Prof: Where the positive
charge is.
There's a vacant orbital on
carbon, an atomic orbital of
carbon that's not shared.
So there's a low LUMO.
Where's a high HOMO?
Have you got that too Virginia?
Student:  On Cl.
Prof: Chlorine has
unshared pairs,
right.
Bingo!
So, in fact,
both those things happen at
once.
It's not that one happens and
then the other.
Both those things happen at
once.
And you can see it by looking
at molecular orbitals.
So there's the HOMO of the
ethylene or olefiant gas,
and the Ïƒ* LUMO.
So those things mix.
The blue orbitals overlap and
mix, shift electrons toward the
other one;
the chloride breaks away.
But at the same time the HOMO
of the chlorine mixes with the
LUMO of the ethylene.
So you're making two bonds at
once, two pairs of electrons.
So you make that three-membered
ring, with two new bonds,
and the chloride,
as we said, breaks away.
Okay, so we've got that
substance now.
And now it itself is reactive.
Can you see what would be
reactive about that cation
intermediate?
What are you probably looking
for, a LUMO or a HOMO?
Student:  A LUMO.
Prof: A LUMO.
Angela, do you have an idea of
what could be a LUMO here?
Student:  The chlorine
has a positive charge.
Prof: It's true that the
chlorine has a positive charge.
Does it have a vacant orbital,
an unoccupied molecular
orbital?
Student:  No it doesn't.
Prof: No,
it turns out it's got two
unshared pairs.
So it doesn't have any -- it's
not like the carbon plus was.
But the plus will make orbitals
low in energy.
So what's a vacant orbital of
this thing?
All it's got is Ïƒ
bonds.
But what makes -- suppose all
you have in your molecule is
Ïƒ bonds,
but you want to have an
unusually low energy vacant
orbital.
Right?
The plus charge will help.
But what orbital will you have?
Student:
Ïƒ*.
Prof: Ïƒ*.
Now you got two choices.
You got carbon-carbon or
carbon-chlorine.
Which one's more likely to be
low energy?
Student:
Carbon-chlorine.
Prof: Why?
Student:  Because the
chlorine --
Prof: Say it --
Student:  Chlorine has a
high effective nuclear charge.
Prof: Right,
chlorine has a high nuclear
charge.
So a Ïƒ*
carbon-chlorine,
would it be big on carbon or
big on chlorine,
Sam?
Student:  Big on carbon.
Prof: Big on carbon,
because the bonding orbital was
big on chlorine.
Right?
This is the kind of stuff we're
talking about.
So Ïƒ*.
And there it is.
Okay, there's a localized
Ïƒ*.
Big on carbon, the black one;
small on chlorine;
and antibonding between them.
Now what are you going to --
there's the low LUMO.
What do you have for a high
HOMO, to react with it?
You have to think back to
what's been happening.
Sherwin?
Student:  The chlorine
one.
Prof: The chloride that
you had at the beginning,
that you lost in the first
step.
Okay, so we bring it over here.
So it'll have good overlap.
It comes up, makes a new bond;
that make and break.
And you get that.
And that was the reaction in
1795 that resulted in ethylene
being called the olefiant gas.
Because this is the oil that
was made, by reacting it with
chlorine.
So that was already a very old
reaction at this time;
the "oil of Dutch
chemists",
because it was four Dutch
chemists who reported that oil.
Okay, so there's one way that
you can fix chlorine,
make it part of a hydrocarbon
molecule.
It's addition to an alkene.
So if the hydrocarbons are
unsaturated, if they have some
double-bonds,
then they'll react with
chlorine to fix the chlorine.
So that's one possibility.
But how about if you don't have
a double bond?
How about if you have methane?
What's the problem now,
in doing an analogous reaction?
Sherwin?
Student:  You don't have
the Ï€ in there.
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  We don't have
the Ï€ in there.
Prof: You don't have a
Ï€.
You don't have a low LUMO.
So you can't do a HOMO/LUMO
reaction.
Right?
These are our model,
saturated alkanes,
like methane,
our model of things that aren't
unusually high or unusually low.
So you have to have another
trick.
And here's the trick;
that the chlorine-chlorine bond
is weak.
It's only 58 kilocalories per
mole.
And one of the reasons for that
is that the chlorine has so many
unshared pairs.
So you mix -- if you were
trying to form a Ï€
orbital in chlorine,
you have two electrons in the
p orbital here,
two electrons in the p
orbital here.
They overlap.
Is that going to be bonding,
if you mix these two orbitals?
You'll obviously mix them.
When you mix two orbitals you
get a lower one and a higher
one.
Will it be bonding?
This one will be bonding but
this one is anti-bonding.
Everybody with me on this?
Now, so Kate,
what would you say?
Is it going to be net favorable
or unfavorable?
Two electrons went down in
energy, two electrons went up in
energy.
But the ones that went up,
went up a little more than the
down went down.
So that's unfavorable.
So having so many unshared
pairs weakens the single bond.
So chlorine has a weak bond.
Now still it's worth 58
kilocalories per mole,
which is plenty strong.
It doesn't just break.
You got to do something to help
it to break.
And what you can do is -- I've
made it in this weird color,
which is hard to see.
Why?
Anybody know?
Student:  The color of
chlorine.
Prof: Pardon me?
Student:  It's the color
of chlorine.
Prof: That's the color
It absorbs visible light.
Now how does it take on energy,
when it absorbs visible light?
Where does the energy go,
in the molecule?
Does anybody know?
Dana?
Student: Electrons are
promoted.
Prof: Can't hear very
well.
Student:  Electrons get
promoted to higher --
Prof: Electrons go from
orbitals to higher orbitals.
So you can put -- and the next
higher orbital is
Ïƒ*.
And what happens if you take an
electron and put it in
Ïƒ*?
It breaks the bond. Right?
That's what happened up at the
top, when the chlorine broke,
right?
You put electrons into
Ïƒ*.
So you can do it with light,
as well as with some HOMO
attacking.
Okay, so we have -- in fact,
I said LUMO when I was talking
about ethylene;
I meant HOMO up above,
I think, some three or four
minutes ago.
Okay, so the bond breaks.
But it doesn't break into ions.
It breaks one electron going
each way, because that's easier.
Okay?
And notice that we draw curved
arrows for that too,
but you draw arrows with a
single barb rather than a double
barb,
when it's just one electron
rather than a pair of electrons
that's executing the motion
we're talking about.
Okay, so now we have two
chlorine atoms.
And now we can do the trick
with the chlorine atom,
because we have this SOMO,
and it can mix with the C-H
bond to make a new bond;
that is, one electron in the
C-H bond now goes each way.
One goes to complete the pair,
to make HCl,
and the other one is left on
carbon.
Right?
So it's very much like the
reaction above,
but it's single electrons that
are doing the moving instead of
electron pairs.
And the nice thing about this
is you still have a radical.
It must be so.
If you start with something
with an odd number of electrons,
and react it with something
with an even number of
electrons,
you must be left,
at the end, with an odd number
of electrons.
Right?
So CH_3 is such a radical,
and it can react with
something, to break another
bond, and it reacts with the
weakest bond,
chlorine.
Right?
So now you have methyl chloride
-- you've incorporated chlorine
into the alkane -- and you have
a chlorine atom.
Why is it neat,
that you have a chlorine atom?
What's great about that?
Student:
>
Prof: Dana,
what did you say?
Student:  That was what
you started with.
Prof: That's what you
needed at the beginning.
That's why you used light,
in order to get that.
But you don't need any more
light now.
Right?
That can go back and start over
again.
So it's a "chain"
reaction.
It's called a free-radical
chain reaction.
And so you can get lots of
products from just one initial
photon of light,
that started this chain along.
So these are two completely
different ways.
The first, the top is an
"addition"
of chlorine to an alkene,
and the bottom is called
free-radical
"substitution"
of chlorine for hydrogen,
and involves SOMOs,
rather than HOMOs and LUMOs.
Chris?
Student:  If you have a
second chlorine radical from the
first breaking…
Prof: Yeah.
Student:  …why
does it break a second chlorine
molecule, rather than using the
other --
Prof: Because they have
to find one another.
Right?
They've gone off -- it'll take
forever before they by chance
encounter one another in
solution.
They'll react with many
molecules.
If you try to generate too many
chlorine radicals,
so the concentration gets high,
then their concentration will
drop again,
or not get so high,
because they find one another
and combine.
But as long as they're rare,
they can survive.
You know what the license plate
of New Hampshire says on it?
"Live free or die."
Okay?
I use that joke later on.
Okay, 1830s to 1850s,
we have this substitution or
type or unitary theory.
It doesn't involve the
plus/minus stuff.
Max?
Student:  Is that kind
of like how CFCs work?
Prof: Is it kind of like
what?
Student:  How CFCs
destroy the ozone.
Prof: I couldn't hear
clearly.
Student:  Is that how
CFCs break down the ozone?
Prof: Yeah,
they involve -- that's a
free-radical chain reaction,
the ozone reduction.
Yeah.
We'll talk about that a little
bit later, I hope.
Okay, so there's more trouble
for radicals,
from Dumas in 1839.
And that is that they had this
-- remember, acetyl radical had
been discovered by Liebig.
So there was this great element
that would survive from reaction
to reaction.
But here was a reaction with
chlorine,
of this kind that Dumas had
been studying,
where you start with acetic
acid, acetyl OH,
react it with chlorine,
and you get a chloroacetyl.
So the element has been changed.
It's been transmuted.
It doesn't go unchanged from
reaction to reaction.
Right?
And, in fact,
it goes even further.
It can react again to give
dichloroacetyl or
trichloroacetyl.
All the hydrogens can be
substituted, as we now know by
the kind of mechanism,
the SOMO mechanism,
we just studied;
free-radical chlorination,
chain reaction.
So hydrogen can be substituted
by an equivalent amount of
halogen, or oxygen,
right?
But all these things you get,
when you change a radical into
something else,
when you transmute it,
have similar properties.
All of these acids -- acetic
acid, chloroacetic,
dichloroacetic,
trichloroacetic,
are all acids;
they all taste sharp and so on.
Right?
So they're similar.
So they don't change the type.
That's where this idea of Type
theory came on.
You get the same type of
molecule, even after you have a
substitution.
So by 1853, four types were
recognized as prevalent.
One was water,
another was hydrogen,
another was hydrochloric acid,
and another was ammonia.
So, for example,
you could have these
structures;
and this drawing with a curly
bracket like this was the
notation used by the people who
did Type theory.
So you have water,
hydrochloric acid,
hydrogen and ammonia.
And you could exchange,
make exchanges,
for the hydrogen.
Right?
Substitution.
So, for example with ammonia,
you can substitute ethyl for
hydrogen and you could get
ethylamine, diethylmanine,
or triethylamine.
But these were all basic.
Why would we say they're basic,
in the sense of acid base?
Why do we say they're basic?
They react with acids, why?
Sherwin?
Student:  The unshared
pair.
Prof: Yeah,
they all have the unshared pair
on nitrogen, we would say.
But they said they're just the
same Type of molecule.
Okay?
Or you could have ethyl
alcohol, which is of the water
type.
Or the potassium salt thereof,
which they would say is the
potassium-ethyl analog of water.
Or of the HCl,
you could have ethyl iodide,
where you exchanged hydrogen
with ethyl, and exchanged
chloride with iodine.
Okay, but in fact these two
things could react with one
another to give this ether;
which is another thing that's
still like water,
clear liquid and so on.
Okay?
Fairly unreactive.
So this particular reaction was
named for the work,
in 1850, of Williamson in
England.
So it's called the Williamson
Ether Synthesis.
And we'll talk about that again
later.
But it's quite an old reaction.
So how about the theory of
these types?
So notice it's unitary,
not dualistic.
They're just things that are
holistic, right?
Not plus/minus.
Dumas said that molecules are
like planetary systems,
like the sun and its planets,
"held together by a force
resembling gravitation,
but acting in accord with much
more complicated laws."
He didn't think it was gravity,
but it was some force holds
this assemblage together.
And Williamson,
Alexander William Williamson,
who we just mentioned making
ether, said this is something
new.
And notice it's because it's a
very young guy that has a new
idea, not like these
imagination-starved older
people.
At this time Dumas was
40-years-old.
He's 4/7ths as old as I am,
right?
So he was really getting over
the hill.
"A formula"
-- the young guy says --
"may be used as an actual
image of what we rationally
suppose to be the arrangement of
constituent atoms."
This is entirely new.
Formulas, at least since
Dalton, were only what the
elements were and what ratios
they're in;
not how they're arranged. Right?
But he said,
"We can think that they're
like an orrery,
which is an image of what we
conclude to be the arrangement
of our planetary system."
Do you know what an orrery is?
It's a thing like this,
you know, where you have a
mechanical model of the solar
system and you turn a crank and
the moon goes around the earth,
the earth goes around the sun,
and a bunch of moons go around
Saturn and so on.
Have you seen these devices?
Okay, that was very popular.
There was a show of Joseph
Wright of Derby here at Yale
last summer.
So butyl bromide,
you remember,
is a residue of radical
dualism, right?;
plus-butyl, minus-bromide.
But there's another name for
butyl bromide.
Do you know what it is?
You know the other name for
butyl bromide?
We haven't talked about
systematic nomenclature yet,
so you probably don't.
But it's also called
bromobutane.
But bromobutane is not two
words, it's one word.
Right?
And that's a relic of the
unitary theory,
the substitution theory,
that it's butane in which a
hydrogen has been replaced by
bromine.
Okay, so Berzelius,
in 1838 when these things came
along,
said: "By reacting
chlorine with ordinary ether
produced a very interesting
compound which he reckoned,
according to the theory of
substitutions,
to be an ether in which 4 atoms
of chlorine replaced 4 atoms of
hydrogen."
Right?
So Dumas says that in these
types you can replace hydrogen
by chlorine.
What would Berzelius think
about that?
What kind of theory is he
advocating?
Remember, we talked last time
about Berzelius.
He was the originator of
dualism, plus/minus.
What would he think of
replacing hydrogen by chlorine?
Lucas?
Student:  It's
impossible.
If chlorine is minus,
hydrogen is plus.
Prof: Right.
So here's what he said:
"An element as eminently
electronegative as chlorine
would never be able to enter
into an organic radical.
This idea is contrary to the
first principles of
chemistry."
Okay?
And in that same paper,
in 1838, he talked about
tartrate losing an atom of water
-- but you mean it's a molecule
-- at 190°.
But the interesting thing about
that,
it's not transformation,
but that this is the first time
the letter R was used,
to talk about a generic radical;
"R"
stands for radical.
Right?
So we still use that.
So, so much of what we do
nowadays derives from this
period.
Okay?
So the principal journal at
that time,
in chemistry,
was the Annalen der Chemie
und Pharmacie,
which was originally the
Annalen der Pharmacie;
but Chemie was added.
And you see who put it out.
It says: "With the
collaboration of Dumas in Paris
and Graham in London."
And Graham is one of the guys
out in front of the building
here.
Edited by Wöhler and
Liebig;
but actually it was Liebig,
he was the one.
And later the journal came to
be called Liebig's
Annalen.
Right?
So he was the one in charge,
but he'd added these other
people, just sort of for show.
Okay, so in 1840,
there were a series of papers
published.
The first of them was by his
so-called collaborator,
Dumas, On the Law of
Substitution and the Theory of
Types.
This was a 40-page paper.
And it begins with this
question, number one there:
"Can one substitute the
elements that play their role in
any simple or compound substance
equivalent for equivalent?"
So can you make a new atom take
the role of an old atom?
And you won't be surprised that
in 40 pages he concludes the
answer is yes.
But immediately following this
is a note from the editor,
which says "Remarks on
the Previous Paper."
And it's by J.L.
at the bottom, Justus Liebig.
And he says,
begins: "I am a far cry
from sharing the ideas that
Monsieur Dumas has linked to the
so-called laws of the
substitution theory."
And then there's another paper,
by another Frenchman,
Pelouze, on "The
Substitution Law of Monsieur
Dumas."
And after that lengthy paper,
there's a letter,
"On the Law of
Substitution and the Theory of
Types,"
with a footnote that says it
was a letter to Justus Liebig.
And you notice it's dated Paris.
And it's the only paper that's
in French, in his particular
issue.
And there's another page.
It's got some curious formulas
in them that have a lot of
chlorine.
We'll come back to that in just
a second.
And it's by a chemist that no
one had heard of before called
S.C.H. Windler -- this letter
to Liebig.
And then the next paper is also
"On the Reaction of
Chlorine with the Chlorides of
Ethanol and Methanol,
and Several Points of the Ether
Theory,"
by Regnault,
who was a French chemist.
Now this is that letter,
translated.
"Paris,
1 March, 1840.
Monsieur!
I am eager to communicate to
you one of the most striking
facts of organic chemistry.
I have confirmed the
substitution theory in an
extremely remarkable and
completely unexpected manner.
Only now can one appreciate the
great value of this theory and
foresee the immense discoveries
that it promises to
reveal."
So it starts -- it's got a
complicated description of all
the --
light that was used sometimes
and the various distillations
and crystallizations,
and the crystals are described.
But he started with manganese
acetate,
which had this formula with the
acetyl radical in it,
and was able to chlorinate --
to substitute the hydrogens with
chlorine.
So there's already a validation
of the substitution theory.
But it went further.
A subsequent reaction exchanged
the O in manganese oxide with
chlorine, and a further reaction
replaced the manganese itself
with chlorine.
And then the final reaction,
the pièce de
résistance,
replaced the carbon with
chlorine and the oxygen with
chlorine,
but still it preserved its
type.
Right?
So it was the same kind of
substance still,
even though it was entirely
chlorine.
"For all I know,
in the decolorizing"
(that is bleaching)
"action of chlorine,
hydrogen is replaced by
chlorine, and the cloth,
which is now being bleached in
England,
preserves its type according to
the substitution laws.
I believe, however,
that atom-for-atom substitution
of carbon by chlorine is my own
discovery.
I hope you will take note of
this in your journal and be
assured of my sincerest regards,
etc.
S.C.H.***Windler."
And there's a footnote,
which says: "I have
learned that there is already in
the London shops a cloth of
chlorine thread,
which is very much sought after
and preferred above all others
for night caps,
underwear, etc."
Now this is,
you'll not be surprised a pun,
because the name is pronounced
schvindler or swindler.
So where do you think this came
from?
Liebig didn't have enough sense
of humor to do such a thing.
Who was the joker?
Student:  Wöhler.
Prof: Wöhler.
So Wöhler had sent this in
a letter to Berzelius,
and Berzelius thought it was so
fun that he forwarded it to
Liebig.
And to Wöhler's
consternation,
Liebig published it.
Right?
>
Which didn't make Dumas any
happier.
Right?
So this was a -- Liebig at
least thought it was funny,
I guess.
Okay, so in 1849 Kolbe prepared
the free methyl radical,
the actual element,
which had never been prepared
before, CH_3.
He did it by electrolysis.
So when you electrolyze acetic
acid it turns out you can get
hydrogen, hydrogen gas,
and CO_2, and what analyzed for
CH_3.
Right?
So he had prepared the actual
radical.
Now, of course,
it was discovered ten years
later that he hadn't prepared
CH_3.
It had that analysis,
but actually it was C_2H_6;
it was the dimer of CH_3.
Okay, but at the time it was
thought to be justification of
the radical theory.
So these two theories were
competing with one another.
And ironically,
both the theories were
supported by reactions that
actually did involve
radicals.
So the oxygenation of
benzaldehyde,
the first reaction that
generated benzoyl,
did in fact involve benzoyl.
It was a SOMO reaction in which
a hydrogen atom was abstracted.
And the chlorination,
as we've already seen,
of a hydrocarbon like methane,
involves pulling a hydrogen
atom off.
And that electrolysis did
indeed generate the methyl
radicals, but they were so
reactive, they found one another
and dimerized to C_2H_6.
So it's just sort of curious
that all these reactions did
indeed involve free radicals,
but no one was truly aware of
it.
So next time we'll see what
resolved all this.